we recognize that Jim Jordan is a clear
and present danger but okay let's get to
the Democrats it's not just the late
night host they have to lie and smear
and freak you out about everybody who
might care about the Constitution might
care about Law and Order and might start
doing some good things on the Republican
side here is uh a guy who really wishes
his name was Barack Obama but instead
it's Hakeem
Jeff you confident that you would have
all of your people here this weekend to
continue to block Mr Jordan that you
have enough votes every single roll call
vote this weekend we recognize that Jim
Jordan is a clear and present danger to
the American people and we are going to
be here for as long as it takes to end
this National nightmare this National
nightmare so look we're going to get to
say on gates in a second first off the
idea that Jim Jordan is a clear and
present danger like the guy believes in
the Constitution he's been one of the
best on free speech he's been one of the
best on fighting big Tech uh twice he's
invited me to events to speak to
professional Republicans about the
important issues of the day and the
media like I've only seen him to be like
a decent guy he's not an ego Maniac like
all of the
[Music]
stuff